bueno hay dos dicen que hay dos momentos
decisivos en la vida y el primero es
cuando naces y el segundo cuando como
que entiendes como que para qué naciste
hace nueve años regresé a méxico después
de vivir 15 años en el extranjero y pues
ya sabes después de vivir tanto tiempo
fuera pues me empecé a reconectar con
mucha gente y una de estas reconexiones
es que me junte con mi grupito de amigas
de la primaria secundaria preparatoria
porque estudió en el mismo colegio por
13 años y pues estuvo muy lindo porque
fue como una reconexión inmediata todas
de alguna manera tenían vidas muy
bonitas se habían construido familias o
habían tenido cosas muy interesantes y
la abrazada estaba estaba muy bonito fue
un momento muy lindo lo que recuerdo de
ese día o ese momento fueron
principalmente dos cosas la primera es
que un sentimiento que una emoción que
tuve los últimos años de la preparatoria
que me acompañó muchos años de mi
juventud ya no existía y se me había
olvidado que lo había tenido y ese
sentimiento era que por mucho tiempo yo
me sentía inadecuada
lo segundo que sucedió fue que una de
ellas ya al final así como como de
resumen o corolario dijo pues qué bueno
que nos vimos porque muchos no nos
habíamos visto en 25 años y dijo y la
que verdaderamente fue la sorpresa que
no se veía venir que iba a ser la
persona que es ahorita es sabrina y me
pregunta cómo lo hiciste yo la verdad
como que labró no me acuerdo que le
contesté en ese momento lo único que sí
les puedo decir es que
después me puse a reflexionar en cómo es
que yo me veía y pues aunque siempre fue
una persona vamos a decirnos ahora una
niña porque era pues que de mis años de
juventud de niña era lo que le llaman
aplicada es decir también esto aprendí
en la vida que para sacarte buenas
calificaciones pues sólo estaba hacer
dos cosas prestar atención y hacer la
tarea en todo no pero nunca fue nunca
fui ni la más destacada ni la que se
ganaba los premios ni la más traviesa ni
la más rebelde ni la más bonita ni la
más popular para nada ni la más nada o
sea nada más acabar buenas
calificaciones y era aplicada
me gusta hacer analogías y como
licenciada en informática me gusta mucho
ser analogías más ahora que estamos en
el mundo digital con el tema de los
videojuegos entonces la verdad no ha
jugado muchos pero en algún momento
jugué alguno de ellos y básicamente lo
que entiendo que todos los videojuegos
son básicamente así empieza a jugar el
videojuego y hay un mundo y en ese mundo
hay diferentes etapas y luego terminas
ese mundo y ya ganaste y te pasas a otro
mundo y así hay muchos mundos
dependiendo del videojuego
una cosa que sucede es que en cada uno
de los mundos es como un tema no sea
dependiendo el videojuego pero hay uno
que es el desierto el otro es la playa o
depende en cada uno de ellos también
otra cosa que sucede es que va como de
muy fácil a difícil y luego no te puedes
saltar este etapas y tampoco te puedes
brincar de mundos
hago esta analogía porque como yo veo la
vida ahora que pues ya no soy tan joven
es que
estos mundos en mí en mi caso han sido
que voy cambiando de paradigmas o de
temas y lo que me he encontrado es que
en ese cambio de paradigmas o de temas
a veces te encuentras en ese espacio que
le llaman el vacío de voice
yo creo que es mi primer cambio estoy
segura que mi primer cambio importante
de paradigma fue cuando yo tenía 22 años
estaba por terminar la carrera
y en ese momento pues estaba por
terminar la carrera la verdad me estaba
yendo más básicamente bien ya trabajaba
a mí a esa edad y para ese momento yo ya
me mantenía yo ya ganaba lo suficiente
para pagar mis gastos digamos y pues
básicamente tenía salud tenía todo pero
como yo me sentía en ese momento era
triste vacía y sola
y no había una razón aparente y lo más
interesante de todo es que yo había
hecho y me había portado bien y había
hecho lo que me habían dicho que tenía
que hacer yo baja en los supuestos de
del paradigma anterior en el que estaba
hoy entiendo que en esos cambios de
paradigma a veces tienes que dejar esa
piel anterior y a veces te tienes que
sentir vacío desnuda para volverte a
reinventar o crear para entrar al
siguiente paradigma pero la pregunta más
importante que me hice en ese momento es
si verdaderamente valía y aquí la
palabra es valía valía la pena mi vida
lo que quiero compartirles ahora es lo
que aprendí y he aprendido a lo largo
del tiempo y que hoy por hoy lo puedo
conceptualizar o lo puedo resumir
el que me ha ayudado mucho en esto es mi
hijo sebastián y aquí lo que aprendí en
ese tiempo es que hay una gran
diferencia entre hacer cosas por llenar
el tiempo o hacer cosas
guiadas por un propósito central de tu
vida y que también tienes esas cosas que
tienes que hacer porque tienes que hacer
como yo tengo que pagar impuestos lo
tengo que hacer
en algún momento dado pues cuando tenía
hijos tenía que cuidar o atender a hacer
ciertas cosas de tu casa y hay cosas que
te gusta hacer y hay cosas que eliges
hacer entonces como yo lo veo es que la
diferencia es que cuando
haces cosas guiadas dentro de un
propósito central lo que empiezas a
hacer es empiezas a crear valor dentro
de ti mismo y entonces las frases esas
de la belleza es interior
y las respuestas se están dentro de ti
es que las encuentras porque cuando
estás vacío cuando no sabes quién eres
cuando no sabes cuánto vales
también me acuerdo cuando era niña a lo
mejor alguien se va a acordar había no
me acuerdo quién era que salía en la
televisión diciendo vales mucho merece
respeto entonces lleva el espejo me
decía vales mucho me des de respeto y no
sentía nada aunque luego en algún otro
libro leí que no lo que tienes que hacer
es que lo estaba haciendo mal yo lo que
tenía que hacer era desnudarme frente al
espejo y decirme qué bonita soy que
linda soy cómo me quiero que creen
tampoco funciona aunque bueno a mí no me
funciona entonces qué es lo que sí
funciona y cómo es que cómo es que
funciona y es una forma y es una forma
de elegir la vida porque también puedes
elegir la vida no tener un propósito
y también puedes no encontrarlo y esa
forma de no tener un propósito y nada
más de ir viviendo lo que se va
presentando es una forma en la que hoy
pienso una cosa por lo tanto voy a hacer
esto pero mañana siento otra cosa
entonces mañana voy a hacer esto hoy
siento que esto y mañana pienso esto
otro y es una vida que yo digo que es un
poquito como un teletubi ahí voy para
acá y hoy voy para allá y está bien el
problema es que no vas conquistando y no
vas creando valor interno
cuando tienes ese propósito y cuando vas
creando ese valor interno entonces la
experiencia de vida es de plenitud
creo que ya llegué también yo sé edad en
donde eso de pensar que uno puede ser
feliz todo el tiempo es un poquito como
un mito y de lo que se trata uno es de
verdaderamente de vivir con plenitud
sintiéndote ese crear valor interno te
da también seguridad personal y
una de las
vamos a decir de las cosas interesantes
que encuentras es que al final del día
te das cuenta que lo que piensan de ti
no te importe porque al final del día
nadie está pensando en ti todo el mundo
está pensando que están pensando de mí
pero nadie está pensando en nadie todo
el mundo está pensando en sí mismo
entonces llega un momento en el que
cuando tienes eso te te deja de importar
lo que piensan de ti porque además no
existe eso y otra cosa que sucede es que
ese propósito no se trata de ir a buscar
cosas allá afuera ir a buscar temas
materiales o ir a buscar metas
exteriores no como desde casarme o tener
un buen novio o tener un buen trabajo o
tener una casa eso posiblemente va a
llegar o no pero de lo que se trata es
de ir creando ese valor y esa riqueza
interna que te va
qué te va creando y te va construyendo
como persona y también vas encontrando a
través de estos propósitos o de este
propósito central de tu vida y no tiene
que ser para toda la vida puede ser en
el momento
hay veces que durante mi vida el
propósito central de mi vida ha sido
encontrar el propósito central de mi
vida a veces como que cuando no sabes no
sabía como para dónde voy es digo bueno
pues voy a buscarle por aquí por aquí
por aquí y en ese buscarle pues a lo
mejor me certifique como maestra de yoga
o como maestra de aerobics o saqué un
curso de algo o el caso que les voy a
platicar es que cuando nace mi segundo
hijo sebastián
me encontraba de nuevo en esos cambios
de paradigma
que tenía yo dos bebés saber y mi hija
tenía dos años sebastián tenía tres
meses y yo me encontraba en ese momento
donde de nuevo me volvía a sentir
como con un vacío
un poco sola eso que tenía mis dos bebés
muy asustada porque yo ya tenía dos
bebés porque no era solo yo
y además de todo culpable por sentirme
así porque a ver cómo me voy a sentir
así si tengo dos bebés sanos y yo
debería de estar feliz entonces en esa
búsqueda fui a uno de estos cursos de
fin de semana y me dijeron pues es que
todo es posible y yo pensé y dije bueno
si tú es posible que es imposible para
mí
y dije bueno pues correr un maratón y
porque es imposible para mí correr un
maratón primero porque odio correr
segundo porque tengo un bebé de tres
meses que estoy amamantando tercero
porque además
d
vivo en miami que es un calor el papá de
mis hijos viaja de lunes a viernes no
tengo familia no tengo apoyo y además
traigo 18 kilos de más todavía del
embarazo entonces me propuse ok
propósito me propuse que temporalmente
iba a hacer eso y les cuento esto porque
hay veces que cuando no la tiene es tan
clara agárrate de algo que te va a
construir por dentro y te va a crear un
valor de algún tipo entonces yo me
embarqué en la tarea entonces me puse a
leer del método galloway y me puse me
acuerdo la noche que estaba platicando
con un amigo mío que había hecho varios
maratones y que yo estaba como sentada
todavía no sé cómo con cuerpo de pasta
de dientes mal apretada que te queda
después de haber tenido hijos
con 18 kilos de más pendiente de a ver
en qué momento iba a ir a ver a los
bebés pero platicando lea este cuate que
llevaba no sé 14 maratones y yo
diciéndole ahí es que estoy pensando en
hacer un maratón y él me dice si tú
puedes y me regala un libro entonces
siempre es el proceso el primer día
camine cuatro kilómetros y cuatro
minutos y corrí 14 minutos corrió uno el
segundo día ya le agregué otro pedacito
más el tercer día hice lo mismo que el
segundo porque estaba muy cansada el
cuarto día no fui y dije qué estoy
haciendo y así me leche todo el año
lo que sí les puedo decir es que en ese
proceso como fue algo que elegí yo no
tenía que hacer pudo observar me
y como yo sabía que no solamente ya en
mi vida sino yo sentía que en ese
momento también la vida de mis hijos y
el resto de mi vida dependía de que yo
pudiera encontrarme en eso y por qué
escogido un maratón porque yo crecí
amypa oyendo a mi papá que no es cierto
lo que voy a decir pero lo que él decía
siendo un corredor decía que quien puede
correr un maratón puede hacer cualquier
cosa tú y yo me la creí y yo quería
correr un maratón porque yo veía a los
que corrían maratones como guau porque
yo ya les conté que que a mí no me
gustaba correr entonces ese proceso
después decir que el 50 por ciento del
tiempo me la pasé mal no me gustó me
costó mucho se lo que es plantar fascia
lo que te duela cada músculo cada tendón
pero en ese momento en el que un año
después en el maratón de chicago después
de 5 horas con 20 minutos
cruce la meta y en ese momento
hay porras pero no te importan premios
obviamente no iba a ganar porque estaba
en los últimos lugares y obviamente no
me metí para eso pero en ese momento
algo internamente se construyó dentro de
mí que me dio una seguridad y me dije a
mí misma
sabrina si tú puedes hacer un maratón tú
puedes ser cualquier cosa entonces
lo que quiero como
terminar y ya para terminar de platicar
de esto es que es una elección buscar
ese propósito central ahora la pregunta
que deberíamos de tener todos es como lo
encuentro no como todo el mundo te dice
el tu belleza es interior cómo puedo
saber o la respuesta están dentro de ti
yo les voy a compartir lo que a mí me ha
funcionado y el que me ayudó a
clarificar esto fue mi hijo sebastián y
son cuatro cosas por donde pueden
empezar y no es un proceso que sucede en
un momento es un tema de ir un
descubrimiento y parte de ese
descubrimiento vas a ir a hacer lo que
todo el mundo te dice conócete a ti
misma sé tú mismo pero a veces uno no
sabe quién es uno mismo no ahora hay
mucho el tema de que si la mejor versión
de ti misma yo me pueda pensar y digo
pero pues a veces no sabemos ni quiénes
somos ciento es cuál es la mejor sino ni
siquiera conocemos la peor yo lo lo que
creo es que hay que vivir ese proceso y
para encontrar cuál es tu propósito les
voy a pasar lo que a nosotros nos ha
funcionado y es lo primero es buscar
en lo que seas bueno no tiene que ser
mejor que sea relativamente bueno
segundo que te guste o que te llame la
atención
tercero que esté alineado con tus
valores más profundos o sea que
realmente sea como dice en inglés fruto
del sol que vaya contigo
y el cuarto punto es que sea el mejor
uso de tu tiempo en este momento porque
tú puedes agarrar inventar algo pero
realmente no es el mejor uso del momento
en este tiempo manejarlo si quieres como
un hobby pero y entonces cuando vas
encontrando eso vas armando lo que viene
siendo el propósito principal de tu vida
el propósito central en ese momento y en
ese momento automáticamente las acciones
que tienes que tomar van a empezar a
llegar te las oportunidades van a
empezar a llegar te ojo también van a
venir retos sobre todo al principio y
muchas distracciones entonces tienes que
estar seguro a mí me pasa que muchas
veces tengo muchas amigas que me sé nada
y no me has hablado no sé de ti yo estoy
en mi propósito pero el día que pueda me
voy a juntar con ellas y yo lo que
quiero es cómo transmitir esto para mí
yo sé que para mí sabrina mi propósito
es vivir una vida plena creando estos
propósitos y hoy por hoy y ha cambiado a
través de la vida hoy por hoy
es esa conjunción entre ser empresaria
ser filántropa y dar conferencias
entonces de repente yo digo esto
y me llaman y aquí estoy entonces
empiezan a darse estas cosas muy
interesantes y
lo que quiero como terminar además de
puedes darle las gracias por su escucha
es decir los siguientes
yo no fui yo no lo tenía claro yo nunca
hablé de lo que iba a ser en mi vida
porque me sabía
nunca fui como muy destacada o se me
veía ya esta se le veía desde chiquita y
yo tenía amigas que pintaban divino otra
bailaba ballet precioso la otra se ve
que iba a ser la super ama de casa en mi
caso no se veía así y yo lo que creo es
que si yo he podido encontrar ese
propósito y irlo como cumpliendo
y pude terminar tres maratones completos
cualquier persona puede muchas gracias
[Aplausos]